ma certitude actifs i-tele pays va
connaître et ça on a tous les deux trois
secondes pour mettre une perruque je
roule ou sa découpe d'accord si on
rigole on perd un pont c'est vrai
d'accord d'accord
attention attention 3 2 à 1
alors on est venus s'amuser
[Applaudissements]
le rapport
oui j'ai même pas parler mon copain âgé
partie attention ça s'est fait assez
fait attention
2 1 j'ai regardé
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
l'étudiant 2 0
il est chaud attention attention les
attentions 3 3
[Musique]
[Rires]
excuse moi mais tu demandes à la règle
et la lumière non mais tout ça c'est
quoi séduire p50 de trois heures je te
refais la nique aux dernières attentes
en battant jeu sargé toi c'est tout les
mêmes m'a dit ah non moi c'est faire moi
c'est faire lâcher plus d'idées alors
attends je m'en [ __ ] une comme ça où
ça va dire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
c'est un copain martin gagné
[Applaudissements]
on
l'arrière-garde 50 collèges et
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais lui dire si lui la réussite
sportive
[Applaudissements]